imagine a russian guy like making love
to a woman i can't
that's probably racist and prejudice of
me but i can't imagine like a russian
guy
making sweet love like a an italian
guy's like yeah but you have to make
sweet love you have to do this for the
it's good for the woman and then the
russian guy's like you take you turn
them around
you take you grab you take but it is a
symbiotic thing you take it
is it it's a give-and-take a
relationship you know you give it you
get it
you give her pleasure she like you take
you
come oh it is over but does she climax
what does she climax
what she doesn't have penis how does she
climax
where does sperm come out of for girl no
you make her feel good you touch the
what the sensor
you touch the and it makes a woman
feel good
it pops out on top of a deposit you say
woman has penis does he have balls
never mind